Andrew Tate and his younger brother
Tristan are in custody in Romania while
police investigate allegations of rape
trafficking and organized crime
prosecutors say that the brothers
recruited victims by seducing them and
falsely claiming they wanted a
relationship before manipulating them
into working in their adult
entertainment chat rooms everyone's been
in love before everyone knows the power
of that emotion and the things that you
do for it any kind of rationale or logic
kind of leaves your body and you find
yourself doing things that maybe you
wouldn't normally do and this is and
this is just another one of those
situations
so look
I don't know the demographic demographic
about your audience but if you're a male
this should be a concern to you because
just think about how they're trying to
frame this what they're basically saying
is if someone falls in love with you or
you fall in love with them
what does how does that work sometimes
you do things for them sometimes they do
things for you so now if someone's in
love with you that person can say at any
time because I was in look that person I
was I'm based on that I didn't have
autonomy and so then for that person did
things to me without consent
that's the extreme feminist world now
we're moving towards and this is
propagated by this documentary
yeah that's a great point
he's gone from obscurity to Global
Internet sensation with his hyper
masculine content promoting male
superiority spreading across all social
media platforms but his meteoric rise to
fame last year came as no surprise to
Sophie it was kind of annoying to see
his name everywhere but I knew I said it
I said it to all my friends it's a
matter of time before they figure out
what's really going on here she spent
months in Romania with Tate believing
that she was Tate's girlfriend but as
you'll tell us later in this program he
quickly became controlling and violence
at his home on the outskirts of
Bucharest
and that's where I'm heading now a
country I've been traveling back and
forth to for nearly three decades
Romania has changed a lot there are
Porsches and Ferraris driving down these
boulevards today and lots of young Tech
entrepreneurs hosing outside fashionable
restaurants now I'm on my way to Andrew
Tate's house
I'm saying if you want to be happy as a
man and you want to have a good
relationship nowadays you better learn
to pick up sleep with and you gotta get
loads of territor some chicks so why did
he leave Luton in the first place and
why Romania in the western legal systems
if a girl says something she needs zero
proof they will come and they will
arrest you and they'll put you on bail
and they'll search your stuff and go to
your phone go for your personal life and
find new things to charge you with it's
insanity and I can't live under the
system anymore so I have to move
somewhere with common sense rules those
Common Sense rules mean that the
Romanian prosecute it seems like he
didn't Escape that he's he's dealing
with the same issues in Romania isn't he
yeah and and and the thing is I mean it
is ironic and I'll give the BBC producer
credit that he didn't reframe that as
other people do but let's reframe it as
making it look like he was trying to
break break the law or he was trying to
find another country where he could
basically break the law of you know take
advantage of women so just to just to
give him some credit he actually pointed
out quite frankly that it is a great
irony that he went to a country thinking
the laws would be not as mental in terms
of the mutual movement and basically man
hit but in reality he ended up getting
stuck about the same situation yeah
which is and they'll say he's too
dangerous to release while they continue
investigating his activities he might be
having some regrets about that earlier
interview this is probably 40 of the
reason I moved to Romania they go oh
you're a rapist I say I'm a [__]
rapist but I like the idea of being able
to just say to do what I want I like
being free
right and just approaching Tate's house
along here we've just been past a big
sprawling Orthodox cemetery and there's
a Rubbish Tip here and a lot of
wasteland is pretty bleak
and it's supposed to be just down here
and I've got to tell you this isn't the
kind of place you'd expect a
trillionaire to live at all
Tate's home looks more like a meat
factory than a social media Stars Villa
if I got here a week or so earlier the
car park outside would be full of
supercars Lamborghinis Bugattis but they
were seized by police after Tate and his
brother were arrested back in December
police also found gold watches guns
knives and money the cars and watches
alone came to 3.7 million euros there's
property and land on top of that
so here this is going to be one example
but it happened throughout many times
where there'll be contradictions within
this show so first of all he highlights
the extreme value of the assets that was
seized so he said 3.7 million
which would indicate that someone is a
wealth if they've got assets disposable
assets of that of that value but then on
the other hand he frames the entire
discussion as trying to say guess what
he has no money it's all fake and he's
trying to demonstrate a certain
lifestyle that isn't uh seeped in
reality so that's one example of
contradiction another thing is that he
tries to frame his house as some kind of
meat factory now it could be possible
and from the pictures it doesn't look
luxurious from the outside but that
doesn't mean that it's not luxurious on
the inside so again it's the way he's
framing it which is to basically mixed
hit look like some kind of psychopath
yeah and you know Jerry's pointing out
here in the chat they keep using the
term trillionaire which I think is an
exaggerated term that Andrew used to
sort of amplifies or others he's not a
trillionaire you know trillionaires
would have yachts and own private jets
they don't they don't rent them you know
sort of thing like
we don't even have trillionaires like
Elon Musk is a billionaire that's it
yeah yeah exactly he's actually and
again that's an example of the media
Tech and his statements literally like
he's not a trillionaire he's just a
wealthy man he's obviously a millionaire
and also on top of that as well I would
say his company and the real world is
probably worth about it is probably a
billion pound company so depending on
how you evaluate someone's worth there's
different different ways of doing it
yeah carry on here
did it all come from how did Tate amass
such wealth Tate was a champion
kickboxer born in America but trained in
a Luton gym
I don't go down hey the guy give me this
black eye he quit first because I bought
him in his face he fell down so I still
won ripped violent and Hyper masculine
it would all feed into his later online
Persona when he left the ring he was
looking for fame and in 2016 he appeared
in Big Brother I don't care if nobody
down there likes me I'm sure by now
everyone's already pre-decided they
don't like me and that's fine so I know
the most intelligent person in this
house I know the most capable person in
this house fact but his first shot a
thing went wrong he was thrown out of
the Big Brother house after videos
emerged with him beating an
ex-girlfriend with a belt later it
turned out he'd also been
so this one is well known through social
media and it shows a lack of Journalism
a lack of either Integrity or a lack of
doing the job properly because in
reality when it comes to this alleged
beating there's significant amount of
videos out there it literally took me
like 20 minutes to find all the videos
that a woman comes out that who
allegedly is being and comes out twice
or three two times and says are
consented and then she comes out another
couple of times to say look I support
Andrew now why that's important is
you've basically got a woman to have
consented and obviously those actions
seem don't seem right so for example
from my Paradigm which is a traditional
Paradigm that's unacceptable but from a
western liberal Paradigm this kind of
King type behavior is is normal we've
seen that from a other International
Canyon about this we saw that with 50
Shades of Gray which is the biggest
selling
um
book of all time written by a woman
talking about very very extreme
King type Behavior
so to pretend that that doesn't exist in
society is completely ridiculous that's
the first point and to ignore that that
woman has come out and and said it was
consensual and actually there's even a
video where she actually says to him
look you're not mad you're not man
enough you're you're not hitting me hard
enough so there's even a video where
she's basically go goading and to say
look do a better job in this role play
so again that's my comments on that okay
been under investigation by
Hertfordshire police over allegations of
rape allegations the crown prosecution
service chose not to pursue in 2019
because there was no realistic Prospect
of a conviction next he launched a
webcam business again and this is what
Vice tried to do as well the issue in
United Kingdom with Hertfordshire police
the try and fame frame it as though you
know what the police dropped it they
didn't want to take it Forward no that's
not what happened what happened was in
the United Kingdom especially in the
past what they would do is whenever some
a woman claimed rape they would take
their phones they would then investigate
them phones and analyze them so they did
that with these two women who claimed
that they'd been you know they'd been
ripped and when they'd gone and looked
at those
um phones what they found is that these
women were sending audio notes to each
other colluding to lie and so when they
saw that they then decide that look
these women are clued in and therefore
they decided to drop it based on that
reason they also informed the women and
said guess what this is the reason the
women informed Vice and said this was
the reason why the investigation was
dropped but Vice as well as Vice people
who were writing much better either
didn't highlight it or framed it in a
totally different Manner and then you
saw on BBC where again they framed in a
incorrect manner you know southern
breeze Breeze over that evidence too
like it it seemed clear to me that the
English authorities found there was
insufficient evidence to pursue it so
they dropped it and you know not just
insufficient there was actually evidence
showing they were polluting collusion
okay okay good point
paying women to perform sexual acts for
men online streaming the content to
potentially thousands of paying punters
it can be lucrative and Tate developed
punter is a British term for WhatsApp
um British so I missed that sorry
British punter yeah
what does that mean punter
I'm not sorry I missed the contents of
Punta could be someone who gambles as
well but I'm not sure I didn't miss the
concert all right and let me just back
it up 20 seconds of play in 2019 because
there was no realistic Prospect of a
conviction
next he launched a webcam business
paying women to perform sexual acts for
men online streaming the content to
potentially thousands of paying punters
oh it just means pain people I think
okay it can be lucrative and Tate
developed a taste for it he wanted to
expand more women equals more money and
he came here to Romania we started this
little webcam business from my apartment
and it just grew and grew and grew and
it got to the point where at one point I
had 75 women working for me in four
locations and I'm doing 600 000 a month
from webcam
in Romania webcam is not just legal it's
booming it's supposed to be the biggest
Center for that kind of entertainment in
the whole of Europe and it's another
reason that Tate came here in the first
place
so sir I mean yeah I was going to say um
it's not legal to run a webcam studio in
Romania it's completely legal yeah
yeah
that's it that's an important point to
know because again everyone's been
framing this whole thing as an
illegality but in reality he said quite
clearly it's legal and you'll see now
you'll go to a studio and let's see how
he frames that compared to the way he
frames
tits webcam business
I really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out